if you want to learn business you have
to do it you can watch the videos you
can go to school and get the inspiration
from it but if you actually want to
learn everything I've learned is from
doing it I think if you're learning how
to start a business right now I think
the YouTube and online platforms have
the most up-to-date content for
University though while like it didn't
help me in creating my Channel or
creating a business or anything like
that it really put me in a mindset of
hey you know what I can actually do this
and also a lot of social opportunities
like networking meeting friends and you
can't do that while sitting on your
computer whether you're in University or
not whether you're watching or not just
do it do something